what's up buddy
you're muted you're gonna have to unmute
yourself bro
yeah here we are hey Rich good night
thank you for having me
all right what do you got on your mind
brother uh well thing is recently like a
month ago I split up after uh three and
a half relationship more or less
um my girlfriend was like 11 years
younger she's from Argentina
um I'm from Belgium so north of Europe
kind of a different uh yeah you live in
Belgium
uh I do live in Belgium but I'm in
Colombia for a moment in May
explains a lot did I talk to you
yeah correctly we were in uh induction
Instagram but um okay so you didn't
listen to me then obviously because
you're back now uh no no
no no well we got back together the
thing was uh we split up for a while uh
got back together
things got completely bad
um
last time by the way sorry what advice
did I give you last time
um we didn't really talk yet I mean we
were in contact on Instagram uh no you
and I when we talked last time what
advice did I give you because you're
calling asking about the same check
uh no I I didn't I wasn't in touch here
with you the first time I'm thinking
about something somebody else then no no
no no no no the only way we were in
contact was uh
no it's a long story short
um I met her in Spain I was living in
Spain like four years ago I moved there
started a business
um apart from my business
first half year I think I was being I've
been with like 30 girls something like
that apart from my work literally I had
almost no free time and still managing
to get a lot of spinning plates as you
like to call it
um I met my girl and like violated the
first basic rule I think after a few
days literally she'll uh moved in with
me
yeah
after a few days like after four or five
days did you invite her to move in or
did she just move her [ __ ] in uh I
didn't really invite her the thing is I
was living in uh in a house in the Hills
three-bedroom house with a swimming pool
and she was literally just moved to
Spain she was working a job
paid almost nothing like you know when
you work on uh near the beach near clubs
where you get to get guys in and
spending money this and that yeah
Argentinian girl exactly yeah okay apart
from from my work I was like yeah it
wouldn't be bad to have a woman in the
house uh good thing was after like two
days literally she uh quit the job
because I told her right away that I
really had a problem with a woman doing
a job like that she got literally a good
job like managing restaurants a day job
also from that moment on she starts
literally paying health for everything I
didn't even ask for it but she wanted to
but long story short
um
after a few days she woke up in the
middle of the night crying like
impossible to to calm her down and she
told me yeah she suffered abuse like a
few months before meeting me I already
felt from the start there was something
you know you feel it when when you've
experience with a woman you feel there's
something wrong so in that moment it was
not really my
um my point to ask what happened exactly
because you know what women tell you and
maybe how they got to that point or more
or less to different things most of the
time
so
um well it turned out that literally she
put herself in a situation while
traveling in a hostile same room with
several dudes she had something going on
with one guy and the other guys in room
well the end of the night they did their
thing let's put it that way
um so this thing was always like really
a pressure on a relationship because I
had the feeling are we talking about a
word that rhymes with grape
uh yeah
um but was it these three guys did it to
her
well two of the three because one of the
guys was having yeah she had something
going on with him while she was
traveling and the other guys literally
uh what she said they published
themselves
um 11 years younger I'm 37 so she's 26.
we met when she was just the turn 23
actually I mean we'll get back to your
story in a sec but I just want to say
it's like these chicks that are
Perpetual Travelers by themselves
are stupid okay because they're exposing
themselves to this risk traveling in
hostels with a bunch of dudes it's just
dumb you know thinking oh Hokey Pokey
everything's gonna be fine no you do it
long enough at some point some shit's
gonna go down like it did anyway go back
to your story so she wakes up freaking
out crying yeah okay is also when when
you go back to like I say Argentina have
been there uh countless times in Buenos
Aires I love the whole
atmosphere as being a man and knowing
your game it's for me it's one of the
best places in the world but then you
also know what kind of women you're
dealing with especially when you talk
about this mindset of feminists and
we're free and we're recall and we do
whatever we want I experienced in Buenos
Aires it's it's one of the easiest
places in the world like you go for a
drink you go on a date not even a date
like just for a drink and literally they
all go back home with you so I already
knew a little bit okay it's the way it
goes there
but also in the beginning of the
relationship I was trying to to have an
idea how many guys she's been with
because I met her at 22.
um and she was like oh it could be in 50
somewhere I literally don't have any
idea
but then when we started to get sexually
active together it really didn't match
with the experience that she had in that
like for me it was literally zero
experience
so I didn't know what is what is right
what is she saying what is is it the
actions so all these things so so you're
saying that she behaved an experience in
the bedroom but she said she had the
experience of 50 men exactly like
somewhere it could be around I would you
don't have an idea I would yeah I would
I would believe the 50 men's story and
trust that she's just lazy in the
bedroom uh there was also
um my my first uh thought so well long
long story short later in the
relationship obviously she started doing
her accounting so we got around this
number which was lower than 20 which for
me still is ridiculously high
um well and in the fact that I met her
when she was 22.
um we went to uh we moved also back to
Belgium because I got a great job
opportunity I left my business to my
brother to manage in Spain but then and
the whole kovit started uh two lockdowns
um I choose to not get vaccinated until
today so they took a lot of my freedom a
lot of my yeah I'm a free guy I travel
all the time I couldn't but we managed
to get through the both
um yeah like lockdowns pretty well the
only thing after a while of course
things open up again and
she's got this feeling oh I need to be
uh free again I need a bigger social
Social Circle uh sorry so obviously I
have a problem with women that think
they can have just a friendship with any
kind of guy and she was started to work
in a hotel she gets attention and like
literally so many times a week I had to
explain that men aren't interested in
her as a friend I mean she's a 20 some
year old Argentinian woman
uh her body is like a 10 literally maybe
in face arguing but I mean unbelievable
beautiful girl and still she comes with
his mindset from oh but women I'm sorry
we are the same and we can be
interesting as well and they just want
to be friends
no the asci is actually so I broke up
recently I got like all boundaries but
still putting in in imbalance everything
I know now but still it's it's the yeah
it's it's this double the feeling from
the heart of feeling what I know
rationally what I should do I mean
okay well let me put a two this way man
because I because I think I understand
what you're getting at here it's like
you're a little bit broken up about this
whole thing foreign
the first things I was pretty much but
I'm asking myself the question am I bro
am I broken because I broke up or just
because of the habit and because we're
not in contact anymore because I'm
always used to controlling relationship
I have a certain level I have a better
question for you to contemplate because
those are interesting things to talk
about but I don't think that they're as
interesting as why are you inviting
women like this into your life
right that is a very good question Rich
the moment that I that I did it I was
completely tired of of spinning plates
but I was doing it in on a ridiculous
level I mean I had my like I say my yeah
but I mean like you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to dig through a lot
of dirt to find gold and even if you do
find gold remember I just finished
talking about this if you get into an
LTR it's going to be more work it's
going to be more taxing
um than just dating when you feel like
it right so unless the goal for you like
are you looking to have kids
no no actually I couldn't say that I am
no okay so if you're at a point in your
life where you're like look I'm not
interested in kids then what is it that
you need with a girl living in your
house very good question that that you
haven't fully vetted yet because you
really can't vet a chick unless you know
her for quite some time like a few weeks
ain't gonna cut it a few months ain't
gonna cut it uh generally speaking the
theory is you need a good year and a
half to really size them up to see what
they're made of before you know if you
if you're gonna take her on as a
girlfriend to invite her into your life
and even then it's not ideal to live
with her it really isn't
it's a good question because one of the
reasons why actually I took the choice
she wanted to get married already for a
while she was pushing to get children
um and I was was my basic question is do
I seem do I see women how long did you
date her before she started bringing
that up
um actually after three months or
something we got engaged but um
you left that out you got engaged after
three months
yeah well I did some crazier things in
my life which I got engaged after a week
with another girl I mean and I also walk
away from them as as fast as I get
engaged don't worry about it but yeah I
did with this one yeah but but I mean
like you don't want kids so what's the
point in getting engaged what's the
point of even getting married if you
don't want kids true no but at that
point I mean now of course and you can
say right now after I don't want kids
like you can say I don't want kids right
now right because that might change for
you in three to six years okay exactly
but yeah the point that I'm making is
the question that you should be asking
is why am I inviting these women into my
life so quickly yes that are so damaged
have you read my book uh yeah I uh
recently downloaded it and I think
there's like 10 pages left to read
um 20 red flag chapter did that resonate
with you this this year is sent to me
the first time in summer when we broke
up for a month and uh I think there were
like uh at least half of them
um so she had 10 red flags you're saying
um
what were you saying like you can
how do you say you can make a woman also
your perfect partner maybe not always
but she did really transform as well to
having a lot of good qualities I mean I
can't did she did she so what what were
five of the ten red flags that stand out
the most
um the past or past obviously
um sexual pass
yeah for sure daddy issues like yeah uh
she comes from a family three sisters
mother father is like well he's I I
wouldn't call him well male anymore I'm
sorry to say Okay
um
yeah this is more because of the uh her
background her sister well and then also
um she never takes any responsibility
for anything that happened in her life
never it's always
um like that
um this isn't an issue with women dude
this is an issue with you yeah yeah
there's some bad women out there there's
some there's some [ __ ] up people but
you're but you're allowing them into
your life you have to have firm
boundaries with women with friends with
gigs that you're doing it doesn't matter
what happens you know to be like you
said that you have a business that your
brother was running with you
yes he's running the business for the
moment because hear me out would you
like let's say you take some of those
red flags let's just take five or ten of
them whatever would you deal with a
vendor A supplier a customer an employee
that would be that would that would have
those same red flags you wouldn't right
no so why would you tolerate with a
woman because she's got tits and ass
I think I think basically the the thing
is to be completely honest which I mean
I've been I have a lot of experience and
there's past a lot of gorgeous women and
with this one it was like all right
she's like 11 years younger look on the
body on this one I mean literally sex
Daily we never skip I mean like you
don't strike me as some guy that's new
with women like you have experiences
right yeah okay yeah but this is the
crazy thing which like in some point I
got so tired of of game let's say and
this is where I made my bad mistake now
I fresh it up of course and it goes I'm
in Colombia what else should I say I
mean well this is what hear me out this
is what a lot of these pickup artists
goofballs like to like give to their
audiences and their customers as game
game game game game game game game right
and you can memorize the lines you can
pick up the girls you can do the same
night lays you can smash you can rack up
The Notches but if you don't fix
yourself first and understand what it is
that you're dealing with yeah my friend
um I used to do these shows uh we used
to call it before the train wreck okay
there's a guy that used to do the show
with Sean Smith I have his book over
here the Tactical guy to women you
should read the Tactical guide to women
by the way
okay it's a good practical guide to
women yeah the Tactical guy to women
um and one of the things that he said
early on on one of the shows is you ever
see those guys on like YouTube or on
like those nature channels where there's
an alligator there with his mouth wide
open and they stick their hand in or
they put their head in every once in a
while and they're doing like a show
and yeah you know for the most part it
works out pretty much okay the show
works but at some point one of those
[ __ ] crocodiles one day just [ __ ]
Clips down on the motherfucker's head
and kills him
okay at some point if you keep playing
this game long enough some chick is
going to pull a number on you and I'm
not saying she's gonna kill you but
she's gonna do something that is going
to put your situation your life your
business something relationship with
your brother in the business at [ __ ]
risk you got to get your head squared
away my man you can't allow these women
because they're hot pretty they're tens
whatever to get away with this stuff but
if I analyze my the women that I was
madly attracted to it is always
something that you know from the start
like like driving a Ferrari without the
brakes you know you're gonna crashing
us I don't know it was something is I
don't know but I mean like the perfect
women or girls everybody's always
talking about it every guy want to have
a long-term relationship with somehow
they don't do it for me I miss this some
fires you don't really want a long-term
relationship anyway you don't want kids
no but I mean also it it kind of had
good things as well the long-term
relationship I mean not with the women
you're dating my friend no no no I know
I know I know are they cooking and
cleaning your house are they able to
take care of you when you're sick do
they run errands for you do they make
your life easier not if they got 10 red
flags no no I know I know I know but
actually no we're cooking the cleaning
the sense so that I was so so perfect I
I I my friend you are addicted to chaos
that's uh probably true I think in more
than one aspect of my life but it's also
a time in uh 37 which
37. okay well yeah my friend I I would I
would prefer guys figure this out by the
time they're 30 you're 37. I look man I
would I would I would take a break from
chasing tail get your head squared away
and make sure that you can get better at
at uh spotting dangerous women because
at some point you know the alligator or
the crocodile is going to clamp down on
your head and shit's gonna be over yeah
very I I I can tell that the way that
you run recklessly it's it's dude it's
like riding a motorcycle without a
helmet at some point you will go down at
some point every motorcyclist goes down
at some point at some point
you see it coming from from far away
already you know you see the crash
coming closer and closer and still you
still keep
on the right because you're like oh
let's see what's going to come next but
no you're 100 uh right my friend um I'm
going to give you that resource again
the Tactical guide to women read it read
my book again uh there's another book
that I would recommend uh Joe Navarro he
was an FBI profiler he wrote a book
called The Dangerous personality types
there's four okay yeah
um he basically took his entire career
dealing with Psychopaths and [ __ ]
crazies and talked about the personality
traits that exist in those people you
like chaos you like inviting crazy women
into your life I get it the sex is
awesome but at some point you're going
to discover that that the chaos that
they bring to you and the [ __ ] and
the stress it ain't worth it I gotta let
you go because I gotta let a few more
people in because I got some people
waiting but I hope and thanks for all
your uh great work okay thank you take
care brother all right hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line tend to in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out